deuxième jour de la visite officielle de
jacques chirac au liban le président
français a passé une partie de ce
vendredi saint en compagnie des
chrétiens libanais les grands perdants
de la guerre civile
avant de rencontrer les casques bleus
français déployés dans le sud du pays
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
philippe harrouard gens quand ce matin
le président chirac était en plein fief
chrétiens à karkh et pour le fils du
vendredi saint célébré par le patriarche
maronite le cardinal sfeir foule
chaleureuse mais beaucoup dans la
communauté chrétienne sont sceptiques
sur la portée de la visite de monsieur
chirac ont par le liban ils répondent
tutelle syrienne s'en contente qu'il
soit là mais on n'est pas content parce
qu'elle vient légaliser la l'occupation
syrienne
le patriarche quitté figure de chef de
la résistance morale des chrétiens grand
perdant de la guerre n'a jamais craint
de parler de politique
lorsqu'il évoque son pays ce qui est lui
mêlé le plus c'est qu'il perd tous les
jours un peu plus de son identité et de
sa dignité de pays indépendant souverain
et jouer sans de son pouvoir de livres
décision changement de décor une fausse
tour eiffel jacques chirac est au sud
liban avec les 5000 casques bleus de
l'onu présent depuis 18 ans il
s'interpose entre le hezbollah pro
iranien israël qui occupe en partie la
région 247 français 24 ont payé de leur
vie
cette mission vise en principe à
restaurer l'autorité du liban nous
souhaitons que l'état libanais exercent
librement sa pleine souveraineté sur la
totalité de son territoire mais nous
voulons aussi et chacun le sait que tous
les peuples de la région dont l'état
d'israël puissent vivre en paix dans des
frontières sûres et reconnues
cinq ans après la fin de la guerre ont
des lois d'une réconciliation politique
au liban le président chirac a pu le
constater le jeu reste complexe et
surtout plein de passion et de rancoeur